in this video we'll quickly review the
differences between
oligodendrocytes are gal cell types
present in the central nervous system
whereas Schwan cells are gal cell types
present in the peripheral nervous system
oligodendrocyte multiple axon so one
oligodendrocytes can only molinate a
single axon so there is a one toone
mapping between Chanel and the axonal
marination then allod endite progen s
are actually neuronal progenitors
whereas Schwan cells are derived from
the neural crest cells so these are the
top three differences between Schwan
cells and
oligodendrocytes which are key gal cell
type in the central nervous system
regulating the myelination
process so it's important to remember
and note that
oligodendrocyte multiple
aons and Schwan cells are present in the
peripheral nervous system and one Schwan
cell melinates one Exon Schwan cells
were actually described by Theodor
Schwan in early 19th century and
oligodendrocytes are particularly gal
cell type which are derived from the
neuronal stem cells so neuronal stem
cells in general can give rise to
neurons oligodendrocytes and also
astrocytes so so there are temporal
regulation which helps to produce
oligodendrocytes it's important to note
that neurogenesis happens quickly
oligodendrogenesis takes place at the
later half of the embryonic gestation so
if this is a gestation timeline in human
then there are different time points
where
oligodendrocyte progenitor cells are
developed then around GW or gestation
week 18 to 28 the immature
oligodendrocytes form and the mature
oligodendrocytes form from somewhere
around 28 to 40
GW so each of these cell types are
differentiated by specific markers so
all of them are
oligodendrocytes in contrast to olgod
dendrite Schwan cells are not produced
from the neuronal progenitor cell they
are produced from the neural crest C
cells so from the neural crest cells
first the uh Schwan cell progenitor or
precursor is formed which starts
attaching and docking to the axons
eventually it start interacting with the
axon more elaborately so axonal
interaction increases still it's an
immature Schwan Cel eventually Schwan
Cel wraps around the axon several times
and there is also interaction with the
Basel lamina at this point of stage it
has matured so now we understand the
development of Schwan Cel as
well now let's talk about the broad
functional similarity between Schwan Cel
and oligodendrocytes so far we have been
only talking about the differences
though they are different in terms of
origin and location where they are found
they have one basic function which is
common that is the myelination process
so why myelination is important because
be it a central nervous system neuron or
pereral nervous system neuron the nerve
conduction requires insulation so
insulation ensures there is no
electrical signal leakage during
transmission also speed salutary
conduction and efficiency is mediated by
this myelination which is done by
oligodendrocytes in the CNS and swanel
in the
pns so due to the Schwan cell the nerve
conduction can happen in the salitary
fashion so it not only improvise the
speed of nerve impulse conduction but it
ensures action potential can jump from
one node of rvea to another so this
particular jumping kind of motion of
action potential is basically known as
uh salitary conduction this ensures the
conduction happens very fast and
sometimes it is really relevant that the
conduction happens
quickly now other than these kind of
functions Swan cells are involved in
nerve regeneration nutrient transport
and phagocytosis when there is a per
nerve injury Schwan Cel take charge to
heal that particular uh injury also
Schwan cels have specific Transporters
which allow the uh allow the uptake of
specific uh uh nutrients from the blood
and it can provide it to the neuron also
it can take role active role in
phagocytosis and clear cellular debris
which might have resulted from the
neuronal injury now let's talk about how
Swan cells can help in neuronal
regeneration process here is a neuron
which is injured so obviously there
would be injury induced neuronal
degeneration or valarian degeneration so
obviously macres would migrate to this
particular region to clear up the debris
eventually the portion which was uh
which was intact it would secrete it
would lead to the production of axon
sprouts and all these oood all these
Swan cells would eventually align
themselves to form the bands of Banger
so basically
so B Band of bangar is basically
oligodendrocytes which are
dedifferentiated and they form a pass
passage way through which these axonal
Sprouts can be guided and this is this
accelerates the process of nerve
regeneration in the peripheral nervous
system now let's put Swan cells and
oligodendrocytes so gulan bar syndrome
is one type of acute rapidly Progressive
dementing disorder which is also
autoimmune in nature in this case gm1
ganglioside present in the swan cells
are targeted by the immune system so
it's a autoimmune disorder which
ultimately leads to destruction of these
or damage into these uh Swan cells and
the insulation of the neuron obviously
this would result in weakness numbness
tingling and all symptoms starts from
the bottom I mean lower from the distal
to proximal area eventually these is
reflected in the electromyography
readings there would be a decrease in
nerve conduction velocity Sharp SMY too
disease or CMT is another kind of
disease which which involves the Schwan
cells so obviously due to a mutation in
the pmp22 gene which is a which produce
some protein which is a component of
mine leads to this particular disease
this particular disease involves muscle
pain cold hand curled toes curled
fingers muscular atrophy Etc all due to
the problem in the Schwan Cel and the
myelination now in the central so this
this is happening mostly the peripheral
nervous system so far now we are
shifting our view to the central nervous
system where olgod dendroid defects can
be important so here we talk about
multiple sclerosis multiple sclerosis is
a particular uh condition where the mine
sheet surrounding the axon gets damaged
and this is happening in the central
nervous system which leads to plethora
of neurological
symptoms so
oligodendrocytic proteins known as
milein basic protein or protein lipid
protein PLP mine oligodendrocyte
glycoprotein or MOG all of these
proteins are not supposed to be treated
as foreign by the body's immune system
because they are present in the oloy in
normal situation but in case of multiple
sclerosis for unknown reason immune
system start treating these proteins as
foreign so obviously there are reactive
cells generated against this particular
protein so autoreactive t- cells further
activate B cells and B cell
differentiated into antibody secreting
plasma cells so obvious viously these
antibody secreting plasma cells Target
specific proteins present on these myin
Sheed and thereby destroying these myin
Sheed in a complement dependent
Manner and that leads to demyelination
in the central nervous
system so be it olgod dendrite be it
schanel we appreciate what were the
differences the key differences were
igod dendrite were found in CNS in
contrast Swan shells are found in pns
hendy mile Ates multiple aons whereas
schanel mate only one hodr progenate
oligodendrogenesis so we have a nice
summary and now if you like this video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to like share and subscribe if you like
our videos please pay via PM PayPal or
UPI support us via super thanks or you
can also support us via patreon see in
next
video